let me give you a couple of updates
everyone knows style last summer sal
told us he was pulling
a 3.9 in college before he dropped out
a 3.9 he claimed he was studying to be
an x-ray technician
let me let me refresh your memory with
that okay
did you uh graduate stuff at community
college uh
what is what's the um no
i don't think i did what were you going
for i was i was going to become
i told an x-ray to get out of the house
pretty much an extra an x-ray what
some people say technician it's x-ray
technologist and i was a science major i
i did well like in anatomy and phys i i
pulled like a 3-9
in in school at 39 i believe that you
got a 39.99
[Laughter]
none of us believe him so we got in
touch with suffolk community college and
sal attended suffolk community college
from the spring of 1989 to the fall
of 1992 with no classes taken in 1991
this is the true academic record of sal
okay
in the spring of 1989 sal failed two
classes
aerobic dancing and reading in the
content
areas i said to someone
at least he took one course that had the
word reading in it
you know but he failed it
in the fall of 1989 sal only took two
classes and didn't pass
either of them he received a d plus in
anatomy
and unsatisfactory in algebra one
finish the semester with a 0.0
grade point average 0.0
the spring of 1992 sal
buckled down and received a b plus in
both
classes he took that semester huh he
took standard freshman composition
and intro to psychology and miraculously
managed to get a 3.5
not a 3.9 a 3.5 gpa
for one semester now according to his
own transcript
sal governoli finished his time at the
school
with not a 3.9 robin but a 2.3
gpa wow now why do you lie about
your academic record be honest i mean at
this point
we all know you're dopey what's the
matter with you i
yes it's a 2.3 for you divided by those
other semesters it's a 2.3 bull when i
got you took
them sal yes yes i i'm not disputing
that but if you
if you if i would have continued on like
my final semesters which was 3.5 i've
proven that i pulled a 3.5 i'm capable
oh no
you've proven that you passed a couple
of classes if anything if you look at
the track record i became more focused
as time went on i went from zero
point three when people ask you when
people ask you what was your record
you said your [ __ ] business that's my
answer all right that's a better answer
point how about that people you know
what's your [ __ ] record what's your
gpa shove it up your ass that's my aunt
that's what you say
that's right now the reason i call they
i'm not being mean but the reason i call
you out it's like stolen valor
when you go around saying that you had a
3.9
gpa that would mean you were a straight
a student you got all a's in college
all right last two semesters was a b
plus 3.5
all right so i'm off by four two
semesters
you don't have an academic all right
you're it's stolen nobody's asking you
about
one year the whole thing has to count
if i never graduated robin first of all
do you know how long it would have taken
you to graduate you're only taking two
classes a semester i can't i don't even
know what you're planning i was getting
my
feet wet howard i was all right this was
something new
i was testing the waters one class at a
time
right you know you tested the waters and
you drowned
[Laughter]
i'm a turtle